well welcome everyone to the next
episode of dc
thursday we have a really awesome
episode for you today that i've been
looking forward to for a while
and most of you many of you in the
community maybe most of you
have heard of the great expectations
data testing framework
and so our guest today is one of the
co-authors of the project i'll introduce
him in a second
but great expectations is an amazing
open source tool that you can use to
test the data flowing through your
systems and
the project debuted a data council i
think it was in 2000
early 2019 and we've been tracking the
project for a while
so we've seen a lot of their growth
we've had the co-founder
and co-author abe gong on the show
before
um but our guest today is james campbell
who is
another one of the brains behind the
project and
um james and i are looking forward to
having a chat about
not just an update on great expectations
the project
um there are some new cool features that
we're going to talk about including
profilers and extensibility but we're
also going to talk about james
background
as an analyst in some interesting
sectors
and so um james i'm really excited to
welcome you to the show
thank you so much i'm really excited to
be here
yeah it's great great to have you here
and you have a really interesting
background so
i want to get right into it um
you were an analyst in several different
types of roles
and i know that includes even some work
for the nsa which
you may or may not be able to share with
us many details about
um but i'm curious to hear a little bit
about the the early part of your career
and how you got into data in the first
place
uh absolutely i it's i was i was
reflecting
as uh as i was thinking about this
conversation on
what the trajectory for me has been and
i think it's really
there's a really interesting dynamic
where on the one hand i've gotten to see
a lot of change and like you mentioned
move between different roles and i can
mention a bit about that in a second but
it has also been
a a very direct trajectory in some ways
when i go back to thinking about my
academic background i actually
recently looked at my college
application
and they asked the question what would
you want to study
and i said and i you know you know at
the time everyone is kind of canonically
uncertain but i i marked down math and
philosophy
because that's what was the interesting
area for me that intersection
and that has really continued to be true
for me and that is what i ended up
studying
uh as an undergrad even and then
throughout my career i've gotten to move
between more quantitative and
qualitative analytic roles right out of
college i
i worked as a economic analyst
we were doing mostly securities
litigation
expert witness testimony and
then then i moved into the intelligence
community like you mentioned
and um you know getting to rely on some
i was really lucky to have
fantastic mentors uh when i was very
young and
and get to work in uh networking and so
i
moved into computer security
and as that became something that you
know we had a tremendous amount of
resources and i got a chance to
grow i think with the zeitgeist into
the big data movement
and experience the perils but also the
joys of getting to work on those kinds
of problems
and now of course you're the cto of
super conductive
cto and co-founder which is the the
company behind
great expectations um how did you
discover that you wanted to start a
company as an engineer
you know i i think it was a it was
interesting for me to think about the
prospect of leaving government i
have always been really drawn to public
service and so i love that
aspect of work um but again in that kind
of
you know trajectory comment i think i i
remember being very interested from a
young age
in the you know the challenges of
entrepreneurship
and in many ways the the problems are
very different
because we're you know more resource
constrained in some ways
um but also the opportunities are
different we have a lot more ability to
uh you know just be out in the community
and being part of an open source project
is not a way that i even realized would
have been possible
in terms of starting a company long ago
and it's been
really phenomenal to just see how much
community engagement
and interest and contribution there is
and how did you get interested in open
source projects
or sort of get involved in that space in
the first place is there a story there
well i've you know i have had
interestingly maybe software engineering
was
was always for me more of a means to an
end
um i mostly was was
learning and and doing coursework
focused around being able to
uh you know solve particular problems
you know whether that was cyber security
questions and take advantage of novel
data sets
um or the economic analysis that i
mentioned earlier
for me i think um the the
benefit of open source was was therefore
just apparent throughout my career
because i i
i remember you know working with hadoop
when it was
literally we had some old computers
under a desk trying to figure out if we
could process
more log data and um
the the idea that we could take
advantage of
uh so much really impressive thought
and work that a huge community of people
had contributed to
was always really exciting and uh
in in my last role in the government i
was with a lab
uh called the nc state laboratory for
analytic sciences
which is sponsored by the intelligence
community and
where our explicit goal was to reach out
and engage more broadly with the
community to make sure that
uh the the best minds in the world
were working on the kinds of problems
that we were interested in
and so again i just felt like i got to
see what incredible things can happen
when you
harness the power of an incredible
community um
and and you know i never i think dreamed
would when
i started working on great expectations
that it would become the project that it
has
um you know we i was looking just the
other day
you know there there are well over a
hundred
different people who have contributed
substantively to great expectations
and representing companies big and small
you know students and professionals um
and and we know of course you know for
every
contributor there are many many more
users so
and and i find the origin story of the
company um
well and the project um both sort of
equally interesting of course
great expectations as the open source
project and super conductive
is the company behind great expectations
but um
you and abe started off doing consulting
correct
and great expectations the open source
tool
essentially fell out of that work as you
were looking for
repeatable ways to do things with
clients um
can you talk to us a little bit about
that and a little bit more about the
origin story specifically of the great
expectations project
sure you know it's actually it's it's
it's even more serendipitous
than that in fact um abe and i have
known each other since we were very very
young
our our parents uh had studied together
uh in the bay area in the 70s
and um we were we were in different
areas you know he was working
in the healthcare space as you know
through and through an entrepreneur
and had worked on a number of different
companies
already and as he was really interested
in making changes
to the healthcare space he saw the
the same problems that i had experienced
in the intelligence community and just
by virtue of having been friends for a
long time
we had a routine call to get you know
the two of us and several other
people that we knew and we were talking
through things that we were interested
in and i said you know i'm going down to
this lab where i can
uh pursue my passion in many ways and
this is one of the things i want to work
on
and he said you know no kidding i've
been working on the same thing
so we began collaborating um
you know for me as as uh purely
uh you know exclusively on the open
source part not engaged at all in my
contract
while he was doing that and then it's
only been since i joined the company
uh about two years ago that we've you
know and then actually only about a year
ago did we decide to really pivot fully
into great expectations instead of
the consulting side well that's a great
founding story it's always illuminating
to understand that the details and the
circumstances surround
surrounding how two founders met because
i know there's lots of engineers in our
community who are looking to start
companies
and that's one of the things that's
exciting to me about
getting folks together data council is i
don't just want them to find
you know career opportunities or jobs or
get smarter
or discover open source i i i like them
to start companies um
when when they're so inclined and so um
you know
being able to match uh founders together
is one of the exciting things that comes
along with that so you certainly have a
gift for bringing
people together oh thanks um
i'm excited to um you know for mass
vaccinations to roll out
for us to be able to run in-person
events again for sure because
you know it's great to see people in the
video in the video zoom screen but it's
not
it's not exactly the same as we all know
um well that's a that's a great sort of
background of
of the company and the project um the
other thing you mentioned that's just
intriguing to me that i have to ask
about is the intersection of math and
philosophy
so before we move on from your
background um is there anything you want
to say about
encouraging people to get a philosophy
background if they actually want to go
into data
you know it's it's funny um
i think long long ago there was this
there was a huge pipeline out of
philosophy departments
into uh software engineering um
in the you know in the 60s and 70s and i
think there's been a there's
always been a really deep link between
computing and
and philosophy whether that's um
you know a lot of 20th century analytic
work and and work on
uh you know fundamentals of computation
um
or what's been and our nation's or and
what's been particularly interesting to
me
is is in the space of really
understanding confidence
um and so i i think there's actually a
way that that we're seeing that
is as a huge resurgence that absolutely
to you know to your point
uh really calls out for a more
need to invest in philosophy and that's
in the space of
explainable ai and ethics of ai
you know as as models become more
complex um but actually i think just as
important as the the relationship
between
the construction of training sets and
the influence of that training set on
the population
becomes more pronounced in other words
where you can no longer assume that
there's independence between
the predictions generated by gen one of
the model and the training data used for
building gen2 um we need to i think
think very carefully
about what we what we want the system to
do
um and in fact in many ways that's the
the philosophical side of great
expectations when i when i've talked a
lot about
uh what we're trying to do sometimes i
use the the phrase analytic integrity
um meaning really uh understanding
with a lot of precision how confident we
can be
in the judgments of any given system
which will depend on
the characteristics of the system but
also of
the environment that it's located and
operating in
so yeah i couldn't i could i could go on
forever about that but i love your i
love the way to frame it you like
absolutely i think there is tremendous
value from
uh being able to draw on the
the work that has come before us in
thinking about those kinds of problems
yeah perhaps it's valid to say that
philosoph philosophy first like to think
in terms of frameworks
they're establishing a framework for a
way to see the world
and it's probably not too far off base
to think of ge
as establishing such a framework and
a language and abstractions and all of
these notions
um in the world of data so of course
some people
just might say that they're both black
arts data and philosophy but
but uh i i think i can understand maybe
some of the
some of the esoteric connection there
so um i think a lot of folks in the
community are already familiar with ge
but um
just before we get into some of the
updates and some of the really cool
features that i know we want to spend a
bunch of time on
um can you give us a quick background of
the project what it does
um the main components of it and how
folks are using it currently today
absolutely so uh great expectations
is at its core about helping people
express expectations about data and
verify that those expectations hold on
data sets
so data quality is really what we're
about
but quality is not doesn't mean that
it's
you know pristine in any particular way
quality is always tied to the purpose
for which it's being used
so it's about being able to draw that
line one of the things that we're
really committed to like you mentioned
earlier with great expectations is
being a language a way of communicating
so
great expectations provides a mechanism
for users to
declare expectations which can be things
like i expect a column to exist in a
table or i expect values in a column
not to be null or i expect values to
come from a
particular set that we've agreed on with
the
product engineering team but they can
also be
uh you know related to aggregate
characteristics i expect the mean
of the values in a column to have some
value or be in some range or
i expect the distribution of values in a
batch
of data to fall in some range and
because
we're in the business fundamentally of
being able to declare
and then test expectations about data
we have a really natural way of
prevent presenting that and so we call
that data docs
and so one of the key features that
great expectations offers is the ability
to
visualize what the expectations you have
are
in a prescriptive way so you know i the
data in
uh this or the the values in this column
should not be null sort of a normative
prescriptive statement
um but then also uh in a descriptive way
um you know like there are 15
values in this column and then finally
putting those together in a diagnostic
way so you can get a
pretty web page that that says there
should be no null values but there were
15 hole values warning and then you can
you can
uh tie that into an alerting system uh
that uh runs
together right in your infrastructure so
we have a lot of users who
for example deploy great expectations in
their airflow pipeline
uh or in whatever dag runner they use
prefect
uh dagster you know there that could be
a cron job
and uh they get this uh this diagnostic
report
about whether the data that they are
processing meets expectations um
so that that's really what ge does um it
it really helps you
declare and and think carefully about
what your expectations for data are and
then validate that they're true
got it and and how many folks do you
have
using ge at the time how do you think of
the the size of the community and i know
it's a growing
open source project but other specific
um things that you get excited about in
terms of
kpis or metrics or how do you think
about that and then the impact that
you're having on the community
great uh great question and that goes
back to our comment earlier about
just being excited to be part of an open
source community um
one you know it's very difficult as an
open source library to say
with with confidence how many users
there are because there are lots of
users
uh who we probably never know about um
but we're really focused on building
community so a couple of the kpis that i
would flag
that i think are indicative of that is
we have over a thousand users
in our slack community now and you know
we see job postings routinely
in there uh you know people can
advertise
uh their problems and and then of course
there's there's support for ge of course
in the community as well
um but it looks like it looks like you
have 2200 people in your slack community
okay over two thousand as of right now
because i just signed in to
to check it out and i see twenty two
over twenty two hundred people so
just a heads up the numbers are even
rosier than you than you thought
i'm underselling that um well so that
the the other way that i think we we
measure community and i mentioned this
one earlier is just the number of actual
contributors into the code base which
isn't
100 uh already it's over 120 i think
um in fact let me try and redeem myself
on the side i think it was 126 when i
looked last week
it's gone up a little bit since then so
those are the measures that i get most
excited about um
of course there are other ways that we
you know we do have some instrumentation
in the library that helps us
sort of see how many validations are
being run
got it well this is a good place to
mention to folks who are listening that
um we do want to take questions for
james in the chat so
if you have questions for james about
his um background or experience or about
ge itself
on the project feel free to to pop them
in the youtube chat
and we'll do our best to get to them as
the show unfolds
um so james i think we
we understand what what ge does some of
the origin story
um maybe going back to higher level
sort of concept um surrounding design
principles i'm i'm curious how you guys
thought through
what you wanted to accomplish in the ge
project because i've always been
impressed at the thought that's gone
into the structure
of that framework and of those
abstractions
you guys are very much abstraction
designers and
in conversations with you and with abe
and even with the rest of the team
some of whom met together at data
council incidentally which is another
cool story um the team's always been
like very thoughtful about the way
they've
rolled things out so um as
as an example i'm curious if you can
sort of explain to us some of the design
principles behind the project
and how you prioritize trade-offs and
what things you cared about um
if you could walk us through some of the
main thinking in terms of
how you thought to the project design
that would be super interesting i think
for our audience
well personally thank you you know it's
it's really been fun to get to have
a community that we can discuss these
things with and i think one of the
things that's really helped with that
kind of
approach to design is that we haven't
been
exclusively focused in one domain um
and and so one of the design principles
is that
we want to become a language we want to
be
declarative and expressive um
that means that we often use very very
verbose names
uh one of the expectations that i i
remember
you know when we were just thinking
through how
how should this work uh was was we
described
literally in in excruciating detail uh
in the name of an expectation what
statistical test
we're going to run and and and then the
the parameters
become the uh the
the the parameters to the test so so
again that kind of transparency
and verbosity are uh things that are
really important
for us and for our users and then as
we've been able to do more work in
renderers and we can talk about that a
little bit more
later but more work around the data docs
we're we're really focused on making
sure that we never
lose hold of exactly what's happening
and and exposing that to users on
maintaining our our credibility first
uh when we're doing any kind of new
expectation
another thing that we really are are
focusing on is making sure that
the prescriptive or descriptive
or any other way that an expectation is
uh is presented it's it's understandable
to as many users as possible and ideally
at different levels
so we want to make it possible to look
into
the result of a validation and get a lot
of detail
while also being able to get a summary
if that's what's relevant for you so
making it easy to structure the
information
right away that's on the
on the expectation side interestingly i
think some of the
most most challenging design decisions
that we've faced
have been around how we interact with
others infrastructure
uh you know there's there's a real
interesting tension where
great expectations is definitely doing
compute right we're computing
the mean of a column we're computing
whether
uh values match or regex using some
other engine like pandas or
your database or warehouse or spark but
uh we also don't want to become uh
a tool that that is used for for
transformation we need to
we need to have our tests live really
close to the raw data that's how the
value comes
uh you know what we really offer people
i think is the ability to
to understand what the data is that they
are getting
as well as what the data is that they
are emitting in fact that's one of the i
think really
subtle design questions is what exactly
do you test
and i think often uh we find that
testing your inputs
is actually more important than testing
your outputs great expectation
in terms of i don't know if important is
the right word but it offers
more insight often to the data team um
and of course eventually i think they
usually mature into doing both
but in terms of getting started so is
that to say that
is that to say that you're trying to
stay distant from
transformation processes and you're sort
of conscious
very conscious of trying not to blur
that line or not encourage your users
as the case may be to blur that line in
their own systems
yes that's exactly right um now again
you know what what we are doing is we
are introducing some of those
capabilities but we're doing it in a
very very measured
uh way and and going back to the point
about
you know philosophy when you think about
the expressivity of a computing system
there are
several pretty clear inflection points
like at what point do you allow somebody
to defer computation or provide a
parameter you know use a variable
instead of a
a parameter that's known in vast at what
point do you fill these variables
in also at what point do you provide for
condition uh in in the flow of computing
at what point do we allow grouping of
data
and so we've we've been introducing
those concepts
in a very careful way so that we never
lose track
of of being data quality like that is is
a core promise that ge
offers um and again just to just to
hit on that on the last thing i was
saying with respect to integrating
with dag runners so um we we absolutely
want people to be able to test data in
whatever transformed
state it is and so we've done a lot of
work
about making sure that we also can be
really clear about what has been tested
so the concept of a data source
a data connector a batch you know what
exactly is running
and and often that confuses people you
know who hear batch and they're like
well can we
can we use ge on streaming data and the
answer is
yes um in for exactly the reason that we
were just describing
where we provide multiple lenses
into any given set of data so that you
can evaluate it for the different
purposes and in the different times and
places that are most relevant
got it um and along those lines
like the i'm sure there's different
philosophies
of so-called anomaly detection if you
think about sort of the broadest
category that maybe
ge would play in how do you compare and
contrast
some of the ways that ge approaches this
field versus
um other other projects or other models
that you've seen
um that that's another one that i really
love as a question
because it lets me it lets me be
philosophical and a lot of people ask
that question all the time
um i think the biggest way that i
like to think about the difference is
that um
with ge there's a huge amount of
intentionality
around exposing to the user uh
clarity of what they are ultimately
testing
um and i mentioned that question about
what point parameters
get filled in and so i think you can
think of anomaly detection
um as as so firstly just
you know you can absolutely express
basically any kind of anomaly detection
using the language of great expectations
uh but what we what we're really excited
about is the way that we
uh bring clarity to what
uh what it is that you're testing the
other thing that's really different or
maybe
so you know we can dive into that uh in
a bit later actually
because we're doing some new work in
that area but the other thing that's
that's just always been really different
is
um and i sometimes like to use from out
of band for this so
we bring out of band information meaning
we're testing data
using knowledge and insights that you as
a data team have derived from outside of
the data set
you know the the the knowledge of what
the acceptable values
for some code field are in general
doesn't come from
inspecting the data set it comes from
understanding the system that's
populating that field
and so we allow you to bring that
conversation with your colleague
into your understanding of the data and
into the testing for that data set
so that you're not ex relying
exclusively on
anomalies in terms of deviations from
what has been
observed past but but more in a fuller
sense of the word anomalies
meaning deviations from what could
properly be expected based on the
behavior of the system
and how how exactly does that work can
you give us like a specific example of
how one might
sort of translate a conversation sort of
into the
the you know from a different business
unit sort of into the the ge code like
what does that look like what does that
really mean
yeah um absolutely and in fact i'll get
the i'll pick an example i think that
that really highlights a lot of the
value of ge
um because it can because we can sort of
play around with at what point that
conversation happens
so um you know i mentioned that uh that
i did a lot of work on
on banking data and banking data it's
common to have uh a given transaction
broken up
uh into different codes and and you know
so maybe there
be uh the total value of a transfer
between two accounts but also
what was the cost basis of that transfer
uh
what portion of the transfers taxes what
you know whether there was withholding
that happened
so there may be a number of different
rows as with with
particular codes now uh
let's suppose that we that a company
offers a new feature they offer a new
product
and they uh they choose to encode that
with a new code in this data set well
there may be a huge number of dashboards
throughout a large organization
that rely on on the data
and so for example if if you have
financial data where
we we might assume that one code is is
the total
and then the other codes represent a
breakdown
of of that total into into sub
components
um if if we add a new categorization or
new code or
tax law changes or there's new
regulation
any dashboard that relied on on
basically summing up the values of some
set of codes
would break i mean it would be subtle
right it wouldn't it wouldn't be obvious
but the but in some subset of the
transactions you you would you would
lose
uh fidelity so uh
the the way that conversation might play
out is you know
in a lot of organizations i've been you
know maybe a data team would basically
send out a big email well we're we're
changing
this system we're you know starting on
march 3rd we're going to add a new code
update accordingly hope you get
that in that that note with great
expectations you could have put a test
and you still can put a test around well
i expect the values
uh for this code to be exclusively
drawn from the set uh that that i'm
summing over
and that way as soon as a new value
appears you'd immediately get an alert
about it
but you're not you're not learning that
from the data because your other systems
aren't relying just on the data right
you you've got a dashboard or an
analytic system that
knows what those code means right
they're actually semantically meaningful
to it
in a way that another anomaly detection
system may not be able to take advantage
of
so but this is a way to just just
correct me if i'm wrong but this would
be a way of detecting
when a value in that new code
emerges not so much the schema
validation
of whether or not the new code is
is is sort of required is that is that
an appropriate distinction
yes that that's definitely true now
you know we just like you can express
anomaly detection you can express
schema validation uh with ge but yes in
that example you're you're absolutely
right it's
it's really about understanding changes
in uh in a complex data system
got it but everybody's system is complex
whether they know it or not right
well isn't that true um but it sounds
but you you indicated that you can also
um sort of describe schemas and then for
schema validation in ge
how does that work briefly so just like
we had
you know i mentioned this values in a
set type of expectation
there are there are expectations about
the
storage type of values in a column uh
the names of columns orders of columns
there are uniqueness you know we could
expect column values to be unique for
example to express a uniqueness
constraint in a schema
so it's really about what the
expectations that you encode are
one of the things that's really neat
about that and this is something one of
my colleagues
has been working on just this week is
that you can
translate expectation suites between
different
environments so you can express a schema
that you know normally maybe would be
you know normally you might express a
uniqueness constraint in sql
as a uniqueness constraint but that you
know that's not something that a
csv parser uh exposes
uh so you want to be able to verify that
a new
uh piece of data valid you know matches
your schema even before it's been
attempted to load so you can get a very
detailed report about what's going on
great expectations is great for
that great that makes perfect sense
well i want to talk about some of the
new cool stuff
in geneva as well because you guys have
been really busy at work
i've seen some great updates fly by um
you know talk to us about what's
happened in the last few months and sort
of what the main categories are
of work that you guys have been doing
you're right this is really exciting so
uh the main area we've been
trying to improve is um well
i shouldn't say domain there are several
areas we've done a lot i've done a lot
lately
so one of the things i'll talk about is
uh the the modular
nature of expectations and this is
really about making it easier
for users to contribute custom
expectations and manage custom
expectations
um in fact i'm going to be doing a deep
dive into
the real guts of modular expectations uh
later today that would become that will
be available as a uh as a webinar
okay with module yeah thank you so with
modular expectations what we're doing is
um taking all of the logic about an
expectation
meaning what metrics it relies on
how those metrics are evaluated and
compared what it needs to return
how it should be rendered in those
descriptive
prescriptive diagnostic ways and
potentially in other languages as well
and we're encapsulating that into
a modular unit a python class that can
be imported at runtime dynamically
and registered and made available during
validation
and so what that means is it's much
easier for people to
encapsulate all of the logic of their
custom expectations which people have
been writing in great expectations from
the very beginning
into something that's portable and
shareable and so as a result we've
actually just just
launched a new package called great
expectations experimental
which is which is built out of a contrib
module
in the great expectations repository and
and where we really want to open up to
the entire community the ability to add
expectations
whatever form they want and really make
that easy one of my colleagues
eugene mandel has been doing a lot of
work around
building up templates and guides and
documentation for making it super easy
author expectations um
there are also some really fun
performance improvements that we get as
a result of
this this modular shift because it
allows us to
store metrics and more easily express
relationships between batches
and so forth and do you have do you have
a mechanism for the community to
contribute
um their expectations back to some kind
of gallery
or i'm not sure if i've heard anything
specifically about that so i don't want
to ask well i don't i don't want to like
i don't want to
you know you just can't you just wrote
the launch announcement i i don't think
we
um well so that so you're you're
definitely
in the in the we have not launched the
gallery yet um but yes
exactly one of the things that we've
done as well uh as well as all the
things i mentioned in these expectations
is we've provided some mechanisms for
you to add metadata
um and and some of you know test
examples for example that are rendered
into a really
a really beautiful accessible page so
that you can
search and find others expectations uh
create them and see them yourself like i
mentioned uh this
repository is now uh published directly
on pi
pi already it's available um for people
to contribute to with a really low bar
we have literally templates for
expectations so
lots more in that space what i was
mentioning is kind of the guts that made
that possible but
you're exactly right where we're going
very very exciting
well we'll we'll be um waiting with
baited breath
for um some official announcements in
that capacity when when the time comes
hopefully soon
yes well well uh the the expectations
extensibility sounds really
exciting um have you seen some good
uptick in
interest from the community in that so
far i'm sure you get
you know early users in the slack
channel and you get early feedback from
folks
um so i assume the the response so far
has been positive
yes um we've still we've still marked
that api
as experimental um and so we haven't
been encouraging
uh people with production deployments to
move over yet but what we are doing is
we're actually sponsoring several
hackathons
uh over the next few weeks where uh
where
people who want to contribute
expectations can have a
live support from somebody on our team
and uh pair together with others so so
it's really
you know bring your idea bring what you
want to be able to express
in the language of great expectations
and we'll help you make that possible
that's great well um con on us to help
you
spread the word to the community to our
community when that time comes so
if folks want to watch the data council
newsletter or the great expectations
slack group i'm sure they'll be
i'm hearing about uh the those hackathon
announcements soon
thank you absolutely um so so what else
i know there's more than just the
extensibility there's
um i've been hearing stuff about
profilers plural
which is interesting to me and i kind of
wanted to ask you about i've been
hearing things about
um well you mentioned these new batch
style
data connectors you mentioned it briefly
um just a few minutes ago
um talk to us a little bit about about
these aspects and what that what that
means
absolutely so for for uh for batches
first i think
you know i mentioned this this idea that
we're making it possible to have a
variety of lenses
defined into a data set with with the
new style data connector and batches
great expectations will
really help you manage the promises
around relationships between batches
more easily
so one of the things that people really
like about traditional anomaly detection
systems
is in some ways it can be a very useful
black box you know
put it on a data set ask it to watch a
number of metrics and say did these
metrics change in a surprising way
it's really useful feature so in order
to
make that easier for people to to do in
great expectations what we've done with
batches
is provide a really strong sense of
ordering
and partitioning of of batches of data
so that with a data connector configured
you can define different ways to slice a
data set whether that's
a load time or whether that's a
date key or whether that's
uh some other key you know that's
relevant for for dividing up a data set
um one of the things that that does
to to get to your other question is
unlock much richer
profilers um so
you know you said why plural well
because there's not just one way
to learn from a data set and so what
we're doing
with profilers is making profilers
composed out of
rules that users can author
and then uh it's possible to just
combine those rules in different ways
and so a rule might be something from
your organization
like i know that we have a convention
where any column that ends in underscore
dt
should be a date time or
it could be that any column that has the
the term id
in it uh needs to be unique or you know
whatever
the conventions or or uh things that you
have in your organization that kind of
out-of-band knowledge
but they can also be things that you
learn like we have we've done some
interesting work around
semantic typing meaning you know looking
at
you know estimating what kind of
of data is in a particular column based
on its cardinality if there's
there's every value is unique it's much
more likely to be an id
whereas there's only a small number of
values maybe this is
a code linked to something else
so with that with profilers what we're
doing is making it possible again to
decompose what your knowledge
is into rules and then we're providing
users several profilers
that also are able to look across
multiple batches
so that you can generate expected
metrics
based on much more information than you
could have
previously great expectations very
interesting
um i want to go to a couple questions
because we're getting some questions
from the community and i think they may
have to do with some of this
functionality
um so brian is asking i've been meaning
to ask your team about a feature i've
been looking forward to the feature is
to make it easier to do comparisons
between two batches of data example
month over month
is this is this the sort of behavior
that you're referring to
yes uh absolutely so um
for a long time we've had what are
called evaluation parameters
um which allow you to uh
defer the the identification of a
particular expected value
uh till a later time and so in the past
that's how users have
handled this month-over-month problem uh
they validate one month's
data and then they use an evaluation
parameter
that describes that observed value from
the previous month
um it's pretty clunky to be honest i've
never loved it
it works but it's it's not really
what we what we were wanting to do and
the reason was
it wasn't it wasn't really clear
how to describe that concept it's very
natural and intuitive for us what what
does month over month mean
but for great expectations we needed
those promises of the data connector
that provides an
ordering of batches so that we can say
okay now have a data connector that
produces monthly batches
and the if i look at the we you know we
use the term partition like i mentioned
and then partitions have an
index so you can just say give me the
previous index
of partition uh now truth in advertising
the all of the machinery is in place we
have not kind of packaged that up as a
feature we
we're planning to uh bring that out
together with profilers
so that the kind of functionality is uh
completely
uh you know baked in there but but
absolutely right that's exactly where
we're going and i'm glad that that
jumped out at you
got it i think it's related to another
question
from the wi-fi i imagine ge is very
helpful when ingesting third-party data
as it could flag deviations and input
data over time
how have people use ge to perform
holistic integrity checks on one source
and track how the source changes over
time it seems like this is a similar
type of use case as far as i can tell is
that right well i
yes although i think often um this is
this is
even a more traditional ge use case this
is very much the one we were describing
where
there are two teams involved um my
favorite way
we had one one team that talked to us
about you know what
what they use ge for is kind of writing
that awkward email to a vendor
that says well you you said you were
gonna give me this but i looked at it
and it's not like that
and that could be you know that's it's
it's a tough email to write because you
know you need to be precise well ge
makes
nice so if you're buying data from an
external vendor
uh you can write expectations about how
it should behave and and how it behaved
in the past
and then if that vendor introduces a new
code or
um you know any number of things happen
the total number of people in the world
goes down instead of up or something
that just shouldn't ever happen
uh you can uh you can look at that
or you can have some real clarity around
what's happened in order to communicate
back to the vendor
got it yeah that makes sense especially
with these uh third-party data sets and
folks integrating these from from
multiple sources um so one more
andrew is asking in the financial
services example you gave
earlier would it make sense for the
downstream systems to publish their
expectations
to the producing system yes
yes indeed we actually have a term we
use for that we call that a data
contract
um and um i think that's really a
phenomenal case
in fact uh with uh with
data docs uh it becomes possible to
publish the uh the prescriptive version
of an expectation suite
you know in a readable form put that up
on a website for example make that
available to them
but yes also to actually share the
expectation suite i think that's
a really good use case got it
awesome great questions and great to
hear from folks
in the community um
so i just wanted to go back to
um to any other
um clarification you wanted to or if you
wanted to dig deeper into profilers
because i know i kind of interrupted you
um you know during that section um is
there anything else in the profilers
that are
interesting for users to know or are
people building additional tooling
around the profilers or is this um
are they are they automatically kicked
off or is this something that's kind of
uh
you know do it once and and um
you know do do it out of band or how how
are people using the profilers so far
i'm just curious
more color there yeah i i think that's
actually an
area that we're likely to see some
continued growth from
from community and i don't think there
has really emerged yet
a standard practice for how that's done
in fact
uh abe and i had a conversation just uh
a couple of weeks ago in which we were
both we
sort of were sharing back and forth some
uh candidate rules that we would have
uh written and and you know i looked at
his and i was like i don't think i would
i think that should be an expectation
sweet not a profiler and he looked at
mine
i don't know i mean i think that should
uh be more automated and and
so we're we're we're still seeing it i
think just like with modular
expectations
one of the things that we're really
focused on is making sure that
it's easy for people to express what
they want with great expectations and
that we can
position the uh the library to become
a tool that's that's ubiquitous that
that
people use to really describe what they
uh what they expect
so the real key thing that i'd emphasize
on profilers is that it's about
it's about composability it's about the
ability to express
what you want and make that easier to
experiment with and um and and
and then of course also for us to help
you know people learn their data better
um so i i think you know i don't i wish
i could say that there is
one profiler to rule them all um
but i think it's also lovely that that
that's not the case that there's so much
opportunity for people to
still uh compose and build
yeah that's great well i'm really
excited to see how the community
takes to these new features and um and
i'm sure you have even more
goodness coming up um this year so it'll
be an exciting year to
to track the the ge community and um i
can't wait to see how
how these things continue to emerge
thank you
thank you very much it's been uh it's
again been really fun and i think
you know there are some things i you
know that to kind of
hint for a second where where i think
we're also going in and
um i think it was brian's question about
about these data contracts
one of the things that we really want to
do is make it
uh easier for people to have those
collaborative
conversations and engagements across
teams and
and organizations so
we've actually started working on
building out some
some sas features around around ge
that will support those kind of
engagements that is really hard to do
when you're working in the space of
configurations and teams and write in
your
your engineering pipeline so i think
that's what i encourage people to
to kind of look out for and for us to
you know we would we'd love to engage
with people on that to
identify how we can best support those
kinds of interactions
and engagements yeah the collaboration
across teams is so important
and um it's gratifying to see how much
has come up in our conversation because
establishing a language and in a process
and sort of the the edges where teams
are able to collaborate with each other
is super important and we've seen that
in the data council community over the
years you know we started off
just as a data engineering community
because that was sort of underserved but
then there's all these edges between
data engineering and data science and
the
the analysts and then and then the
business users who are sort of consuming
the analysis and so
um i i like how you guys are sort of
going for this collaborative
collaborative
model and trying to establish a baseline
and common ground
so that teams can start to work with
each other on some of these
hairy horn thorny data problems so
yeah absolutely thank you well i just i
wanted to ask you
um before we let you go uh if you have
any advice for
others who are thinking about starting a
data oriented company
is open source the way to go um would
you
i mean obviously that's the road that
you guys chose with ge and that's
maybe circumstantial or maybe that was
the universe
um you know sort of putting a new lap
but do you have any advice for other
engineers or analysts out there data
scientists in our community who might be
thinking about starting a data oriented
company
i think going way back to where we
started this conversation
for me i've always been passionate about
improving our ability to understand
something and
and and having a core problem in mind so
i think uh the the things that i find
most exciting the kind of tooling that i
have found most exciting is where
you're addressing uh a need that's
tied intimately to a business problem
or an analytic problem and
one of the big changes that i see
happening that's that's
driving this next generation
of change in the data ecosystem
is the the much tighter integration of
data production and consumption to
business units
there's much lower barrier now for
every analyst to be able to look at
and create data sets which is which has
created these incredible benefits
and and and therefore the need for
communication that we're addressing with
great expectations
but there are a raft of other uh related
problems and and i think being tightly
tied to
why the you know whatever the human
aspect
of the data system is is is the thing at
least that
at least for me that that's what i i
find most uh fascinating and i think
it's just so important not to lose sight
of
yeah that's well said um and and what
surprised you most about
your work in the data ecosystem so far
maybe apart from
sort of the importance of the human
element is there is there anything else
that really stands that stands out at
you that you
that you didn't expect
i think the level of of community
engagement
i couldn't have anticipated um
you know i was thinking oh well you know
we'll we'll offer upgrade expectations
and it'll be done you know data
scientists will put it in the front of
their notebooks and data engineers will
uh put it into their pipelines and and
sort of the world will be good
never could have realized that you know
there are just so
many smart people out there who are
willing to
participate in building something uh so
impressive
you know i think for example we've
gotten
multiple integrations with uh other
dag runners uh you know with alerting
systems and tools
uh people have written integrations with
different storage ends for storing in
and accessing expectations um
and you know and they're just the world
is full of incredible people so i just
can't always get excited about that and
it's really fun to
see that in practice yeah that's great
it's great to see the community
um you know uh bond together around some
of these projects and
and really appreciate them and offer
feedback and support and
um and guidance usage it's uh it's
tremendous to be able to we live in a
really amazing
time um in the open source world where
we're able to build these projects in
full view and
um with digital community tools like
slack and others to
get information distributed immediately
it's uh it's quite rewarding to
to build a company sort of out in the
open and i think you guys are a great
example of how to do that best
thank you very much yeah thanks for
joining us james um this was a really
fun conversation and it was really um
awesome to be able to chat with you for
an hour absolutely i
i've loved it as well and and thanks for
putting this together and
and again i think bringing so many
people together it's really
fantastic yeah it's our pleasure
and uh to the community out there um
thanks for joining us
this episode we hope that you enjoyed it
you can sound off
uh in the comments there's a comments
link in the youtube chat if you let us
know
how we're doing we really appreciate it
so that we can continue to make dc
thursdays
more beneficial and valuable for the
community
also if you're an engineer founder who's
looking to get your own company off the
ground
i've been offering office hours the last
few months and it's been
really rewarding for me and hopefully
for the community as well
so we'll put a link in the chat if you'd
like to avail yourself to one of the
office hour sessions that i have coming
up
um i love to talk to technical founders
about starting their own companies
and um and how we can how we can best
support them
using the resources that we have and
it's the amazing experience that we have
here in the data council network
um finally don't forget to subscribe um
so that you get notifications for
future episodes and we're looking
forward to our next event on february
4th
where we're having bar moses from
monte carlo who'll be our guest so make
sure you tune in then
and i'm sure barb will have some
interesting perspectives on
data monitoring and data quality as well
since it's such a hot topic in the space
right now
so thanks again to james and all of you
and we'll see you next time